unfortunately the biden agenda is
failing so much so fast the biden white
house is now being mocked all across the
globe as i told you it would happen even
saudi arabia now taking aim at the never
ending biden harris blunders in a recent
comedy sketch on saudi tv this is pretty
embarrassing pretty humiliating for our
country we are much better than this
take a look
today
we're going to talk about the crisis
pain
yeah we're going to talk about the
crisis in africa
yeah russia yeah russia
and i want to talk about the president
of russia
approaching
putin
listen to me i have very important
message to you
the messages
and the president of china
oh he didn't finish russia
thank you to correct me first lady
thank you very much
god bless you and god bless
thank you all
hallelujah president come out to your
prison right now
under biden harris american adversaries
are emboldened our allies are losing
faith in the imploding biden presidency
and sadly it's only getting worse by the
day here for reaction fox news
contributor
new york post columnist author of the
bestseller laptop from hell miranda
devine is with us
so early in the campaign i was out there
kind of standing out on a hanging on a
little branch a little twig with a
little leaf left over from fall and
saying to the world what was clearly
obvious that nobody else wanted to say
joe biden looked weak frail and was a
cognitive mess
the media mob like they ignored the
hunter laptop story that your newspaper
printed two weeks before the election in
2020 uh they ignored it and they
protected joe now he seems to be in a
precipitous decline and it's getting
worse but what i said miranda is it's
not only the american people that see it
that's one thing
but putin sees it president xi sees it
kim jong-un sees it the muellers in iran
see it america's adversaries see it that
to me is where the danger lies not so
much that we're being mocked everybody
sees it but nobody wants to say it why
look that's so true sean and it's i
guess i guess americans are very kind
people and they don't like to
mock or make fun or point out joe
biden's age and you know he's a he's an
old 79 cognitively and um he he fades in
and out and you know
you're right our adversaries and friends
overseas are mocking him talking about
it just running the clips
because it seems so absurd that this is
the leader of the free world and he is
so weak
so frail and uh you know that saudi clip
that's on saudi state tv they have
camilla harris there is a man dressed in
drag who is propping up the president
who is at the very end she's standing
behind him and sort of making his arms
move like a puppet um that's pretty
frightening that's the view that people
have of the president and the vice
president let me ask you a hard question
isn't that the view of everybody in
terms of the world watching america
aren't they all seeing that aren't they
saying what people in america are are
maybe saying more quietly
um
maybe not amongst people that they don't
know very well the problem is
is that you know you could talk about
it's it's not nice to to talk about it
but what about the people that are
putting him in that position
nobody talks about those people
well i mean number one i would say jill
biden dr jill his wife um you know she
knows better than anybody what his
cognitive health is like it was pretty
clear during the election campaign and
very beginning of the election campaign
that he wasn't all there his own son
hunter biden used to joke with his
psychiatrist about his dad being senile
so his family allowed him to be in this
position
it's quite pitiful he's obviously
exhausted most of the time and it's
getting worse
it's getting worse that's extremely
dangerous not just for america but for
the world great book laptop from hell
and it's becoming more relevant every
day miranda devine thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else